just like the other question is
illogical
and i've heard you speak about it
because you all i'm not being solicitous
but you
you're always straight up about what
you're doing and the question is whether
or not
we should be in a position where you uh
um
are why can't the the
the experts say we know
that this virus is in fact uh um
uh is it it's going to be uh or assuming
we we know why all the drugs approved
are not temporarily approved
but permanently approved
hey you remember when trump had a typo
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yes
is scary so before we start the
monologue a lot of viewers have been
asking about cat timf as you know she
had some minor surgery so she's off this
week
but i figured i'd check in on her being
her boss so uh cat how you doing
i will be back on monday
so you heard of the self-fulfilling
prophecy
it's when you adopt a goal that
influences your behavior in a way that
causes that goal to become reality
it's like emily capano wanting to work
with the greatest talk show host ever
and here she is not for long anyway
she's getting on my nerves
but if you think but if you think you're
never going to go anywhere in life you
won't
if you look at others as achieving at
your expense leaving you behind
you will be left behind likewise if you
believe you can achieve
greatness barr getting a job at cnn it
will happen
but if you focus on division you will
remain divided
the power of positive and negative
thinking are two sides of the same coin
and you control the flip it wasn't
always like that especially for blacks
the scale was weighted against them
but unless you're asian trying to get
into harvard discrimination is illegal
the democrat legacy of jim crow is gone
all that's left are the accusations
that it isn't the left is convinced that
the scale is not only weighted against
minorities
but that the scale is permanently broken
which is just not true
unless stelter used it recently
all that's left is dishonest hyperbole
where voter id is what the media calls
jim crow on crack
i call this the media fulfilling
prophecy what if the media creates a
narrative that it reinforces daily until
it feels true
to those who consume it i don't think i
even need the what if in that sentence
it's a what is and it's the only way cnn
can get a story right
to create it then hammer it daily until
it becomes
real gallup has a new poll out on race
relations and it reveals that the number
of people who say things are good has
hit a new low for
two years straight meanwhile 57
say race relations are somewhat or very
bad
gallup admits the survey was done at the
time derek chovin was sentenced
which is like taking a poll that asked
the question do you think it will rain
today yes or no
in the middle of a tsunami it turned bad
between 2013 and 2015 with gallup
linking this to
the several high-profile killings of
unarmed black people by
police officers they were high profile
but a better term would be narrative
fitting there's no questions those cases
upset black and white americans alike
there's even more agreement about that
than our own hatred for andrew cuomo
but the media has like a dose of magic
mushrooms distorted our reality
go outside and observe the interactions
between fellow earthlings
in commerce at work and conversation at
the gym
steam room where i do my nude pilates
life just rolls on and why because we
all want the same things
netflix pizza and clean underwear no
matter the color we want to enjoy our
lives be safe and secure enjoy a good
game eat a good hot dog stand in line at
ace hardware in our bright pink leggings
we all want effective law enforcement
but with all with as little abuse as
possible
now compare that to the cnn lens on
american life
it's a dystopian nightmare of oppression
nightly this elite
activist class pits whites against
blacks without ever considering the
consequences
meanwhile this narrative that america is
racist gets crushed nightly
by news footage of thousands of black
and brown people pouring over the border
if this country is racist against black
and brown you might want to tell them
before they come
i bet joy reid's already on the case and
the cuban protesters must be totally
confused to see american media
on their country the country that ended
slavery jim crow and instituted
affirmative action on behalf of blacks
but still
it is fact that you see everywhere you
look in black and white
the biggest terror threat in this
country
is white men most of them radicalized
right up to the right
at the core of these voter suppression
laws in my judgment at the state level
is white supremacy simple as that we are
reaching the point where
the white supremacist jim crow
sensibility
are devouring the very energies and
souls of any democratic possibility
yeah that made sense the obvious point
racism exists just check a coke employee
training session
but it's harder to actually find these
races today you want to ruin your life
be a racist so the left contrives racism
today expecting kids to learn math is
white supremacy geology is racist
comedy is racist the only thing not
racist is racism against white people
that's
why so many hate crimes turn out to be
hoaxes there's such a shortage of real
hate crimes
that we got to concoct them to meet the
media's demand i'm thinking about
starting a production company
that specializes in staging fake hate
crimes
i have a call into smollett's people
look things can always get better
because things are always worse
somebody should tell cnn who still
thinks it's 1955. it's ironic that
people who call themselves progressives
are stuck in the past but to deny that
it's gotten better is not only dishonest
it's harmful
it's like the condition munchausen by
proxy the media
keeps telling us this nation is diseased
with chronic racism
when it really isn't until it is what
does the angry white male think
are things better or worse well i can't
complain
good food good wine nice weather
oh you said in terms of race relations
right
yeah i don't mind discussing that
subject why don't i just have a sip of
wine first
[Music]
probably a wise move but what does the
angry black male think
hey what's going on everybody gene here
just filling in for tyrus he's going to
be right back real soon
everything between me and him is super
groovy couldn't be better if you got any
questions hit me up okay
hey gene thank you so much hey you got
it tyler it's good to see you bud
sorry man traffic was a mess no problem
hey can i get you something to drink
no i'm good you sure positive okay one
more hug
come here you know what come on in yeah
all right
good to see you pal oh all right thank
you gene
what a nice guy what
[Music]
so what if the legacy media wasn't part
of this recipe what if the news was
reported without increasing discontent
for the purpose of profit yeah and men
can have babies
we live in an era where social media
props up a desperate dying press
so it's become less profitable to dial
down strife
we must be at each other's throats
because the angrier we are at each other
the less likely we can unite against
them racial discord protects those in
power
who keep the pot of hate simmering while
they hide in their snow white
neighborhoods
behind 25 foot iron gates
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
he gives new meaning to the words
florida man
former florida congressman trey roddell
she knows more about security than a
baltimore armored car driver former
state department spokeswoman morgan
ortega's
if she's on our panel one more day she
gets a free ice cream sundae
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
and he's so massive his seesaw partner
went missing
by massive sidekick and hosted upset on
fox station tyrus
[Music]
well you know we're out of time oh we
got to go to the b
block sorry tyrus yep i figured that you
know
you're not a racist but you damn sure
are sizes you're always
see-saws the equator's my belt
i take bass in the atlantic ocean like i
get it you're mad i'm big you're small
let's move on i can't
what's your question white man all right
um
when you look at how how cool look me in
the eye when you talk to me white man
let's get this over with i'm thinking
how vast is the gulf between the media
perception
and the reality of race relations
how deep how vast how vast yes
you see what he did there he made it
about size again
well in this in this situation
if i was going to since we're going on
size yes
i would say it's gut-felt-like
[Music]
not tyrus-like so it's small it's small
the whole point of the angry black man
was to point out
how it really is now the twitter world
and the woke world
wants to make it seem like we're at each
other's throats right but we're not
like the race relations on twitter are
horrible because it's fantasy world you
can be anything you want
yeah you have to be yourself you can put
put a picture of a cat on there and say
that's you
i get it good but that narrative is not
really how it is
because we just don't see the violence
there's no attacks i live
in mandeville louisiana not by choice
but i ended up there
but when i go and i'm a regular guy when
i go shopping
in the store and stuff people come up to
me a lot of older
white women yeah at first i was like huh
what what oh
i didn't do anything i didn't take
nothing what do you want to talk to me
and say hello and they say things like
you know what tyrus you need a hug today
and i'll be like apparently i do
and i'll hug them but now one of them
steps back and goes jungle fever check
the bucket list
you know what i'm saying like we they
i'm part of their community
and they care about me just like and i
care and i know their names and stuff
that is what america is really about but
unfortunately
no one's gonna buy that movie yeah
seeing me quietly walk through a
supermarket and
various people of sizes shapes and
colors and ages saying hello hello
oh you're getting the pickles go with
this did you see what was on sale today
hey john
like that's boring what they really want
is when i walk in
the lights go brighter the manager goes
price check on negro walking through the
aisle
he's now making a left at the butcher
watch him watch him
oh oh no oh god he's going to the
watermelon dear god dear god
no that's not how it is it's not it's
sexy would probably watch that because
we're sick
but we're okay yeah we're okay
you know i would agree with you except
when i see what emily wore tonight
oh yeah what the blue shoes no
you i do not see she's wearing nothing
but white
no she's had some blue thank you morgan
emily's darker than me i thought she was
on my team
there you go well i feel the same way
that you do tyrus
and i felt that in this poll and this
article coming out as well that it sort
of reflected on the fact that so much of
people's
wokism and advocacy it's really just
performative that's the whole point
so i saw in there that there was a surge
of optimism
among black americans about a year ago
when they felt that
for those who had experienced racial
inequality it felt they had
that people were starting to wake up to
and that they really were starting to to
have a voice be amplified
and then it started to dwindle and now
it's next to nothing and i think the
whole point is that they
saw that everyone is like okay so if we
get the pronouns right if i hang this
sign in my yard
if i say this if i put a black square on
instagram then we're cool right
yeah right and so i think the whole
point is that they're recognizing that
those who are actually partaking in the
conversation at this loud shouting
twitter level
and they're putting symbols out there
and these things that matter it's all
meaningless
all of it is meaningless the actual
things that would amplify and lift up
communities
of color uh communities with low income
et cetera that's things like school
choice
that's things like low taxes right
that's things like
lessening regulations in in the towns
and those are the conversations that
those woke people aren't having another
and that's why you need this race
this race narrative because everything
you just mentioned is not a liberal idea
so they need this and it brings me to
this impossible experiment trey you're
in media and i'm in media
the impossible experiment would be what
if the media shut down for one month
how would the psyche of our nation
improve also if it just
where where all you had to judge life by
is what uh tyrus said about the
supermarket
what would happen it would it would be a
beautiful world
yeah but before i talk about race
relations yeah and i'm just deferring
everything to you
um yeah i mean look we all live in our
echo chambers and when you're being told
constantly that the world is terrible
that racism exists but even just look at
the way that certain words have come
into the american lexicon
in just about the last five years white
supremacy
white privilege and when you're
constantly sharing that narrative
and hammering the people over the head
with it that's what they're going to
believe
you shut off the media i think you have
a much better world but
the media can't do that they can't go
away from that because
and nor can the politicians this is
about money and power
and with money it's a business model to
sell hate just like tyrus was saying
nobody's gonna buy the nice one like uh
hey look at we all get along
and if as long as they're doing that
they're selling they're selling their
click baits
to the eyes that tune into the tv and
with the politicians
it's even worse it's it's about money
and the way that they fundraise
every freaking email that you get about
race relations are terrible i'll solve
it
uh to the way that they utilize it to
garner votes
yeah and it's it's it's sad because
you can't even have conversations these
days look
i i uh i speak a few other languages i
backpacked all over latin america not
because i hate brown people
because i love culture living in
different cities in america
but i think what sucks is that i as
someone who loves to talk about culture
interact with people and learn
i'm not going to be the first to just
start bringing up race relations with
people
and you and you'd be backpacking that's
you're culturally appropriating exactly
how dare you know it's true me speaking
spanish is is seriously being called
cultural appropriations
yes it's about elaine you have to stay
in your white lane morgan
i've been telling you that forever i
have on white cowboy boots
stereotype that's a dog whistle to the
aryan nations yes
how am i supposed to respond to that
okay
because i like white i didn't think it
was really i mean i don't like it that
much i changed the color but i'm the
only guy not wearing white
white is uh white is not a color it's a
shade
it's very educational um so no i trey
i like what you were saying about
talking to each other it made me think
so when i was in middle school
i went to a predominantly black middle
school it was a charter school
my parents couldn't afford to send us to
private school and they started these
charter schools in florida where i was
from
to integrate the schools more and i
remember
in elementary school in middle school my
grandfather who i spent a lot of time
with because he was sick and at home
sat me and my twin sister down and
explained to us
what happened that there used to be
different fountains and i remember this
vividly as a kid
that my parents had the conversation me
and said there was different restrooms
there was different water fountains
there was different places at
restaurants that
were white and black people could sit
and i remember vividly as a kid not
being able to understand it and i just
kept asking but why but why
my point is these conversations need to
be had in the homes
amongst friends amongst neighbors where
it doesn't need to be had
is on twitter as you were talking about
tyrus and all these places where people
are just attacking each other and are
nasty
but as a country if we can have these
conversations in our churches
with our families with our friends get
outside of our comfort zone talk to
people of different races
i do think that the country can heal and
thank god
actually most of the country is not on
twitter yes
that is true it's like 10 people yeah
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else